The Joe Rogan Experience yeah 93 that's
when I started fighting imagine that
that's how old I'm a freaking fossil I
remember in 90 I think it was 94 or 95
uh I watched Pedro hizzle work out at
Beverly Hills Jiu Jitsu and that was
when I realized how hard someone can
kick you in the left oh yeah yeah yeah I
watched him kick the heavy bag and I
don't think there's ever I've never seen
a human ever in all my day I've seen a
lot of people kick yeah I've never seen
a human kick harder than Pedro oh he's
an animal because she's got technique
and he's got the weight and he's got
these giant [__] legs yeah oh my God
yeah get kicked by him it's not fun he
was he was kicking the bag and I
remember thinking
yeah I'm not one of those just I
remember when he fought Rico Rodriguez
he kicked Rico once and Rico was
delicious
[__] is that freaking thank you yeah
look at that look he spend so many
around it
air Pedro here's a dance ever and fall
until he stopped dance ever with leg
kicks I mean his his [__] leg kicks
were insane
I mean Randy Couture when he fought him
like they they had a really convinced
Randy to to fight him a second time and
you know he had he had battered his
[__] legs Kevin Randleman too
although he knocked out Josh Barnett too
and it was a lot of that his [__]
Muay Thai and he was Marco who Oz's
prize he's his number one pupil Pedro
hizzle was the [__] man oh he's
another one that people forget
Pedro hiso his [__] leg kicks man and
I'm telling you when I I've seen so many
people kick the bag I no one has ever
impressed me with a leg kick a low kick
on the bag like Pedro hiso look at the
size of his [__] legs yeah yeah I
mean they're tree trunks and he just had
this power that was you couldn't take
them and this is before the calf kick
you know this is early days he was
[__] people up with just kicking the
thighs
uh as soon as he hit you a couple times
it was just like oh Jesus Christ
that's it that's it I'm done I'm done
please please stop this fight please
referees were a little bit more lenient
back then and these are Fighters imagine
this happening to a person on the street
oh okay if you don't know what a Loki is
you're not flexing well Forrest Griffin
kicked a reporter he has some deal with
the reporter he said I'll do an
interview with you let me kick your leg
oh and he's not holding him back any he
full power low kicked and put a hairline
fracture in this dude's tibia
oh was it tibia or is it it's a special
steamer one one of the one of the major
bones
we just had to sign somebody oh yeah oh
this is it yeah oh no
oh god oh yeah oh you know this is
he didn't even kick him full blast
no I I don't think you can I I literally
you're gonna break it would be evil it'd
be evil
hairline fracture of the femur yeah yeah
yeah Jesus Christ don't reporters if if
someone says that to you say no thank
you I would rather not interview you sir
Shrine with uh with my wife at this
whole bus people are yelling out of the
bus it just gets
and they stopped the whole bus and they
come out and they want me pictures and
they want me to hit them oh God so I go
you know and he goes thank you but they
look at me like [__] and I go what is
the look at my wife says I I think you
have to hit him on her I go serious yeah
I go come back
[Laughter]
in his shoulder I love it and then I
start kicking the crap out of people's
legs it's fun but uh you know they were
much happier that's the weird thing they
want you to hurt them because somehow
that makes it I don't know I don't get
it I don't get it I don't didn't Jason
Ellis let uh Chuck Liddell in his prime
punch him in the arm full blast I think
there's a video of that that's not a
smaller thing Jason Alice is a
psychopath though he's yeah he's crazy
yeah he I think he's very funny I think
he enjoys a little bit of pain yeah
there's something about that gentleman
yeah here it is this is Chuck in his
[__] Prime too oh no okay
oh oh yeah oh I don't yeah
in the arm as you see Chuck's he he
wanted to go you saw him yeah they're
looking crazy he gets crazy
oh yeah chocolate that's another one
chocolate Dell in his prime was a
[__] monster yeah because he could
take it yeah he could he could take a
shot in the chin so good that he would
just [__] Wade forward almost daring
you to hit him and just [__] laughs
and then when he would win he would
it's freaking exciting crazy man he made
the UFC in 2005 when the UFC became
popular it was popular because of the
forest Griffin that that the big final
between Stefan Bonner and Forest Griffin
and The Ultimate Fighter made the UFC
everybody watched on TV they're like
what is this this is wild but then you
got to see the champion yeah you got to
see Chuck Liddell when he was all
[__] put up Chuck Liddell versus
Babalu see if you can find that he was
hunting people yeah he was hunting
people and he was a wrestler that never
wrestled he never uses wrestling in the
Octagon other than to get up he just
wanted to [__] you up you know and then
he was really good at it and trained by
John Hackleman whose old school just old
school that that place that he had in
San Luis Obispo the pit yeah where he
would make these guys do it he was like
the originator of all these crazy
workouts with wheel barrels and [__]
there he is
chocolate dough man people forget he was
a [__] monster because he was a big
tall light heavyweight he was a huge Guy
Crazy power and you couldn't take him
down yep his wrestling was incredible
and Babalu was tough as [__] yeah Babalu
was another guy elite elite fighter
Babalu was a [__] animal man there's
a crazy Baba loose soccer kick knockout
of this really thick muscled guy forget
who the dude was but Babalu cracked him
and then soccer kicked him and so oh
oh see if you can find that let's see if
we can find it she would find that you
gotta give Babalu his props because
Babalu is another guy of a guy that
people forgot a [__] there it is is that
it yes I forget who the guy was so he
gets it yeah it's right before that boom
I mean with wrestling shoes on back then
yeah right because they would let guys
fight with wrestling shoes Brad Kohler
is that who it was I forget who the guy
was I think that's Brad Kohler who was
another tank
God damn those early days those early
days
they're crazy when guys would fight with
wrestling shoes on which is very
interesting because
you know you could you could do so much
more with movement and with that grip
from the wrestling shoes I just had an
uh evangelist asked me to uh for a
student of his to for karate combat so
I'm at the show and he's already there I
go oh this is two months ago they
already allowed you I go yeah man I'm
looking forward to this
but he's you can see that he's trained
by Eaves you know but if that was also
one of those guys that you should keep
an eye on he did the the one knockout
that he did one time Josh Thompson uh
the the jumping knee when you had to
single leg did you ever see that yes I
always thought my students I go if
somebody has a single leg on you imagine
you jump up with the same legs that you
jump with him in the face and then land
on that same foot again yeah freaking he
pulled it off yeah Eve was Elite man
yeah Eve was Elite man so here oh this
is this is the Josh Thompson kale and
this by the way this is when Josh
Thompson was one of the best in the
world so it's in a scramble they they
break loose here Josh Thompson gets up
and Eve catches him right here oh and I
remember that with a jumping round kick
and then Josh Thompson was the first guy
to ever stop Nate Diaz yeah I was there
the same kid yeah yeah uh head kick head
kick of Nate Diaz